We've been going through the generations of organic chemistry from Lavoie Zaa to
put Salesian gay loot sock to the Dumas Leebee can volar.
And last time we got to Cooper and began with [inaudible] talking about their
discovery of our invention,
really a valence,
the t in particular,
the Tetra Valence and the self linking of carbon.
But the other thing that calculates most noted for is the structure of benzene.
And we started looking at that a little bit last time with his sausage diagrams
for,
for drawing a structure.
And this time we'll go on in more detail with that idea in the determination of
actual position and add in molecules,
the positions of atoms and molecules.
And this is largely due to students of calculus.
So the next generation Ville help them Kerner who was both in Germany and in
Italy as you'll see.
And uh,
you know,
Honda's Hendrick has spent off from the Netherlands and also Albert Ladenburg
from Germany.
And we'll even have a little message of your own.
Uh,
whoops.
What happened here?
Oh good.
Okay.
Well we won't send,
but we presumably we'll launch again here and get back.
I think I saved it.
Uh,
and there were no,
uh,
where are we here?
UPS wrong one.
Awesome.
If we're lucky.
This is it.
That's still loading.
There we go.
Okay.
So we Kerner Fan Toff,
Loddon Borg and EAP Kohler who uh,
uh,
is your,
great,
great grandfather academically.
Okay.
So Benzine and molecular structure.
This is the simplest of the so called aromatic compounds.
Actually.
Obviously the name comes from the smell that it has an aroma,
but it was generalized from benzene,
which benzene was discovered in 1825 by Farah Day,
who isolate is what called bike carburete of hydrogen,
which was c two h according to his formula.
But actually it's c six h six cause he had the carbon doubled and it's six times
what he thought it was.
And he got it from gas oil,
which is a byproduct quite a bit.
You get a gallon or they did at least then,
I don't know what happens nowadays.
Permit for making a thousand cubic feet of the oil.
That was an illuminating oil,
uh,
or illuminating gas.
Pardon me?
So in 1833 Mitsui [inaudible] named the compound benzene instead of Bicarb,
you're out of hydrogen.
And the origin of the name is interesting.
It came from Gum Benza,
one via benzoic acid.
So you knock the CEO to somehow off of Benzoic acid and you get gum and you get
a what Mitchell is called benzene.
Now Gum Benzo in itself has an interesting etymology because it came originally
from Lou Bon Jovi,
which I'm told is Arabic,
meaning Frankincense,
that's lube on and jolly is from Java.
So it came from the Southeast Asia.
But when the French saw this name,
they assumed that Lou was like La,
la,
and so on articles.
So they knocked it off so it became Bon Jovi,
which doesn't mean anything in Arabic,
but that then became benzoin and then benzene.
Okay.
The French in 1841 named the the the alcohol version of seed faith unique
because it's an acidic and we'll see you why shortly.
Uh,
we call it funnel and we call c six h five fennel and abbreviate it,
Ph for fennel or fee.
That Greek letter for fennel.
And it comes from [inaudible],
which means to bring light because of its association with illuminating gas.
Okay.
So we know that calculate a structure for benzene is hexagonal even though he,
uh,
he wrote it with that sausage thing originally.
And now why?
On what basis did he think it was hexagonal?
Well,
this is the paper where he proposed it's hexagonal,
and I'll show you all the evidence he gave in his arguments for its being a
hexagon,
first,
all aromatic compounds.
So for example,
Benzaldehyde as well as benzene and so on,
even the simplest,
are significantly richer in carbon than analogous compounds from the class of
fatty substances.
Okay?
So it's rich in carbon.
That's the first evidence that it's a hexagon.
The second is that aromatic compounds as per fatty compounds.
There are numerous homologous substances.
That is those whose composition differ by an integral number of ch two groups.
So if you,
if you replace a hydrogen by a methyl group,
you add ch two,
right?
Or if you put a ch two into a CC bond,
it,
it becomes a little bit longer a homologues.
So there are homologous substances in the aromatic series.
The third line of evidence was the simplest aromatic compounds contain at least
six carbon atoms.
Okay.
And the fourth line of evidence is all reaction products from aromatics
substances show a certain families similarity constituting the group of aromatic
compounds.
More vigorous reaction can remove part of the carbon,
but the major product contains at least six carbon atoms and decomposition stops
at this point,
unless there's complete destruction of the organic group,
for example,
burning it.
And that's it.
Those are the four lines of evidence.
So would you conclude from that?
That benzine is a hexagon,
it's quite a stretch.
So was this just a wild guess based on the idea that carbon should be tetra
Vaillant and even in a sense that doesn't help much because there was a question
of what you do with that last valence of carbon.
Right?
So he did have some support for this,
but he didn't cite it in the paper.
He didn't publish it until later.
It had to do with counting isomers.
Okay.
So remember this was the formula he drew in 1865 of chloro benzene.
But in the next year when he started trying actually to say that it was a
hexagon,
he drew a hexagon.
He didn't try to use his sausages at this point,
and he contrasted it with what you'd get with a triangle of carbons with a
carbon in the middle of each edge.
Okay?
So he labels the,
the vertices,
the carbon atoms,
F and counts isomers.
And this is his table of that count.
So Mano Bromo Benzine,
there's only one form,
right?
Obviously,
if it were a chain of six carbons,
you could have it on the end or the carbon that was next to the end of the
carbon.
Next to that,
right?
So there'd be isomers.
But in fact,
only one was known of Mano Brahma.
Now,
how Bout Die Bromo Benzene?
It turns out that their three modifications,
he says Ab,
AC and ady.
How about a
[inaudible] would be next.
Nearest neighbors like AC and a f would be like a B.
Okay.
So three modifications that's consistent with its being,
uh,
with it's being,
um,
a hexagon.
Now how about dry?
Try?
Try.
How about tried Romo Benzene?
There are three drive modify Cotsen and,
okay.
ABC.
So all successive right?
Or skip one.
How about if you skip to,
how about a B?
E
should we have that one?
Okay.
How about Abe?
Kate,
what do you say?
Should we count a B?
He is another one.
Steve,
what do you say?
Why not?
Cause I asked.
Yeah,
but I wonder if you agree.
Maybe he's wrong.
There's precedent for people being wrong.
Okay,
Sam.
Right?
Because if you count the other way,
be a,
he is the same as Abd,
right?
You'd go two in a row and then skip one.
Just go the other way around.
Okay.
Cause it shouldn't make a difference which way you go around.
Or there would be ace,
right where you skip every time,
but there's only one way of doing that.
Okay.
So three modifications.
And if you go to four or five,
six,
it's the same thing except hydrogens are what you count instead of bromines.
Okay.
So that was consistent with experimental observation of how many isomers there
were of these mono di and tri substituted benzenes.
Yes.
Kevin,
what was he using to observe?
So how would he know they were different?
That there were three different substances?
Suppose he had them,
he had to prepare them.
Of course,
maybe they were not preferable.
Right?
In which case you'd have an account that was too low.
But how would you know you had three different things?
How could you tell things were different?
Yup.
Boiling point.
Melting point.
Color maybe.
Although these aren't colored a density,
some physical property you have to measure,
right?
The analysis obviously is going to be the same cause they're isomers.
But you have to,
and of course if you're not very good at measuring things,
you might get a melting point between two samples that differs by two degrees.
You guys are experienced in lab.
Does that mean they're different?
What he say Wilson,
your experiences that it doesn't tell they're different.
Okay.
So it's not,
it's not trivial.
You have to be a good experimentalists.
You have to be able to prepare them and you have to be able to tell when things
are the same and when they're different.
But if you do,
then you can count isomers.
But you have to bear this in the back of your mind that you might be making a
mistake because of your experimental observations.
Okay.
Now,
how about if it were a triangle?
Right?
Then if you had a Mano Bromo Benzene,
you could have the Bromo either at a or at B,
although it's conceivable you couldn't prepare one of them or one of them would
be reactive for some reason.
Okay.
And if you had to,
you could have a B or a C or B,
d or a d,
there'd be four modifications instead of three,
assuming you could prepare them all.
Right?
And then you can go on to the tribe Romo and see there would be six.
Okay.
So by counting isomers you could get information about the structure.
In fact,
the paper that I xerox this from,
uh,
had written in an old brown ink,
the letters from the bottom,
u,
k,
e k,
e l going around the ring for a,
B,
c,
d,
e,
F and w written next to these things was names for the compounds,
elew,
Keck and so on.
Eka Luke echolalic for the order of these things.
You see what's funny,
right?
No Echo lack,
they said was Arabic for hexagon.
That's what was written in the book.
So you got humorous in all ages.
Okay.
Now let's try a applying the idea of ice,
her account to see if we can distinguish among doers,
models of benzine that I showed you.
Uh,
so first there's the one up top and center,
which is what we call the calculate structure of benzene.
Okay?
Single Bond,
double bond.
How many isomers.
Okay.
Uh,
how many mano substituted isomers if you put just one bromine in and that we're
this,
if that were the structure are faithful representation of the arrangement.
How many different ones could you get?
Yeah,
just one.
Okay.
All the hydrogens are in that sense equivalent.
How about if they're die?
How many could you get?
There's one,
two,
three,
four,
five.
Right?
So are they all different
cage,
what do you say?
You say the purple and the red are the same.
And anything else?
The two blues are the same.
Uh,
now does everybody agree with that?
Sherwin?
Perfect.
Aha.
The red one is across the square and the the,
the purple one is across just a single bond,
right?
So those are different if this model is faithful in that respect.
Okay.
So,
but we should take that one out because that one goes across both the square and
a single bond.
Oh,
that's somebody else.
Okay.
Now,
so there'd be four die substituted isomers if,
if it were that and calculate found three right now.
How about if it were this structure,
how many mannose,
if you replace just one hydrogen,
how many different hydrogens,
Elizabeth?
Six.
They're all different,
right?
So there'll be six Banos how many dies?
Well,
let's count them.
So we'll start from the top left.
There would be those sets of dies,
the ones connected by those arrows,
and then we could start from the top are probably five of those.
Then we can start from that one and there'd be four and three and two additional
ones and one from that.
That hasn't been counted before.
So we'd have 15 die substituted isomers right now,
how about if a,
these notice for these two that in both cases it's Aa,
BB,
a in the bottom one,
it's turned on its side,
but the same relationship,
the symmetry of it,
right?
Everybody see that?
Okay,
so these will have the same number of isomers even though their structures are
obviously different,
but the same number of isomers.
So,
uh,
there'll be two mono substituted isomers either an a or a B,
and now we've got the dyes to figure out and that turns out there'll be six.
I'll let you do that yourself.
Okay,
so two six there.
Now how about if it were this,
which is a,
a BB cc because it doesn't have as much symmetry and the redwoods don't have as
much symmetry as the blue ones,
although they're the same as one another.
So it turns out they're three Banos a or B or c and there nine dies.
And you can work those out if you want to.
Okay.
So you can't distinguish among the red ones or between the blue ones,
but you can distinguish a black one from a aqua one from a blue,
from a red.
Okay?
So again,
you can get information about structure by counting isomers if you're good
enough and you can prepare them and you can tell them apart.
Okay,
now here's the problem for you to do for Monday.
And you can work in groups if you want to,
but take that this is a,
a planer and two dimensional,
right?
But in truth,
because carbons or tetrahedral,
when they formed for four single bonds,
the others are not planer,
right?
And I've drawn here how each of them would look in three dimensions with some
things,
the wedges coming out toward you and other things,
the dotted ones going back into the page,
right?
So if you consider these in three dimensions,
how many isomers can you get?
Right?
That's the question.
Mano and die substituted.
Isomers will you be able to distinguish these if there are three dimensional and
uh,
that one,
remember it's called dewar benzene.
And the one that's not included was prison main or what's called Loddon Borg.
Benzine.
Remember I said we'd talk about Loddon Bork?
He's coming up.
So that's another possibility.
A three-dimensional symmetrical prism,
right?
Which obviously do or couldn't make with his models because they would,
unless he distorted and bent them.
Right?
Okay.
So the question is how many motto and die substituted isomers can you get from
these if they're three dimensional.
So you guys can get together and talk that over and tell me on Monday.
Okay,
now there's another way to get a to infer structure.
And that's from synthesis.
So calculate in 1867 reported that three acetone molecules shown on the left
there you see the c double bond o and two methyls attached to each central
carbon.
So three of those come together at a,
at be,
at sea,
losing water.
All right?
And they form the double bonds on the right.
So if that's the way the stuff forms,
then the carb,
the three carbons in this compound called Masuda Lien should be on every other
carbon of the ring,
right?
Because of the way it was put together by losing waters between them.
So that's another way of figuring out where something is by synthesis.
Notice incidentally that there are little dots in the middle of some of these
bonds.
Why do you think those dots are there?
I think it's because this is a picture of a real model that was made with wire
coming out of balls and that was the thing that screwed them together.
Right?
Dewar had sent to calculate when he wanted to come work with him.
A set of these brass strip models,
so this is,
I think is is his version from brass strip models.
Notice the funny bonds between the carbon and the oxygen,
the double bonds,
those triangles.
Those are made of stiff wire that comes straight out and then were fastened
together at an angle.
Okay.
Here's a picture actually of the model that calculate used in his lectures to
show benzene and you can see that the carbon is tetrahedral.
Okay.
Yes.
Yeah.
That,
that he made up in 1890 this is long after this.
It's conceivable that he had such a dream,
but it was a story told for amusement.
Okay.
So here he is at the time he did this in 1865 in Ghent,
and he was surrounded with some,
uh,
hot shots.
Kerner,
for example,
uh,
who was a young man,
he acted as calculated secretary at this time as well as a lab worker and
suffered from rheumatism.
He came from central Germany,
uh,
and which is a very sort of damp place,
a lot of the time and cloudy.
And so it wasn't good for his rheumatism,
nor was getting to in Belgium.
So on his doctor's advice,
he went to Sunny Palermo in Sicily.
Uh,
so is down there on the northwest coast of Sicily.
And Cecily is a very interesting place in history.
It was liberated in 1860,
just before this time,
after 2,700 years of occupation by successive cultures.
Okay.
Uh,
and the most recent one was,
was Garibaldi who came down,
uh,
with his,
his,
uh,
red shirts in 1860 to free Sicily from the borbons,
from the Spanish crown.
Okay.
And condit sorrow came along and established this laboratory in Palermo,
uh,
in 1860,
he helped both Garibaldi and the late [inaudible] God dro and gay loose sock.
Both of these were revolutionaries,
although in different different senses.
Garabaldi was revolutionary politically and avid.
God Rowe was revolutionary about knowing the atomic weight and molecular weight
of compounds through gas density,
but in his way,
Cannizzaro was a cautious person.
This is what he said when he spoke in London in 1872 on chemistry teaching.
He said,
above all,
we should take care that the pupils do not form to themselves any mechanical or
geometrical conception of the cause and effects of the quantum valence that is
the valence of Adams.
They must frequently be reminded that chemical facts neither approve nor
disprove anything relating to size,
form continuity,
distance,
relative disposition,
et Cetera,
et cetera of the Adams that is don't use these arguments for this purpose of
finding where things were.
Atoms are in molecules.
This is just a fancy that will appeal to students,
but isn't anything real.
This was a very cautious,
conservative point of view,
but it was shared by all the leaders in chemistry.
If we are sometimes obliged to speak of the relative position of atoms and the
molecules,
and even to give graphic representation to these positions,
we must hasten to remark that these figures are nothing but artifices of the
mind intended to represent to the site that which in reality,
we perceive only through the veil of transformations.
So it's only through reactions that you try to infer something about this.
It's not something real,
but that we do not really know what it is that corresponds to that,
which we call position,
either in space or in the mutual action of different portions of matter.
But he was one of the leaders,
right?
The followers,
the students were more,
didn't take this right?
So Kerner who had just come down for his health and joined condit sorrow in 1869
he came down,
he came down to 1866 I think,
or seven.
He wrote a paper called facts serving to determine chemical position in aromatic
substances.
Right.
So a completely different point of view from what Cannizzaro advocated three
years later,
right.
To determine position.
And the re Cannizzaro to be fair to him was saying that you have to be different
in what you teach and what you do.
Research on teaching should be things you really know for sure.
And research should be things where you're trying to push the push back,
the frontier.
But any current erode in this paper in 1869,
the dogma of the impossibility of determining the atomic constitution of
substances,
which until recently was advocated with such fervor by the most able chemists
is,
is beginning to be abandoned and forgotten.
And one can predict that the day is not far in the future when a sufficient
collection of facts will permit determination of the internal architecture of
molecules.
A series of experiments directed towards such a goal is the object of this
paper,
right?
So that's what he's trying to do.
If he came along,
um,
uh,
50 years later,
what would he have used
to find the position of atoms and molecules?
X-Ray.
Right?
But he's using only reactions and counting isomers right.
So only the properties of things and elemental composition.
Okay.
Facts will permit determination of the internal architecture.
So this was a really new idea and the paper when it was published was introduced
and warmly endorsed by Cannizzaro who went on to say later that the,
that you shouldn't be teaching this to students,
but it is a good thing to study.
Okay,
so current had,
there's a thing called the Kerner proof,
which indeed he proved,
uh,
but it's not what he did in 1869.
But this is very interesting.
So you have among die substituted isomers you have these possibilities.
Okay.
Now how could you tell which is which?
Suppose you had three bottles.
One has black,
one red,
one blue,
but they're not colored.
They're just white crystals.
How can you,
or liquids maybe in this case,
how could you tell which one is which?
How could you put a label on the bottle?
What you could label them just with names,
call them something like Ortho,
Meta and para,
which doesn't mean anything,
right?
But how do you know which structure they have?
Corey
can't hear very well.
Oh,
that differences in melting point will show they're different.
But how do you know which one will have the lowest melting point?
You have to have some theory about melting point as a function of structure,
which didn't exist or do you have such a theory?
Uh,
polarity but,
but,
but notice to be,
uh,
yeah.
Uh,
one of them would be non polar,
but people weren't measuring polarity at this time.
So that was out of the question.
Okay,
here's how current or did it,
he added a third identical substance substituent and counted the isomers.
So suppose you start with the black one,
you add a third one down to the right or down at the bottom or,
uh,
and that's all because if you added down to the left,
it would be the same as down to the bottom.
And if you added over to the right,
it would be same as down to the,
over to the left to be the same as down to the right.
Everybody see that you can only get two isomers starting from there.
If you start from the red one,
you can get either of those.
Can you get anything else
from the red one,
Andrew?
Yeah,
down to the left will be a different one.
So you'll get three from that one.
And how about if you start with the blue one and put a third one in?
Maria,
what do you say?
If you start with the blue one and put a third blue substituent in.
Speak up a little.
Uh,
right.
You can get the one in the middle.
Yeah.
Nothing else,
right?
The only one.
Only one possibility there.
Okay,
so one we'll give one one,
we'll give to one.
We'll give three.
Suppose it into all the reactions work,
right?
So what establishes the identity not only of the dye substituted but only also
have the tri substituted isomers one comes from one of the original bottles.
One comes from two and one comes from three.
So you know it pretty clever.
And these were called [inaudible].
These are called now Ortho Meta and pair up.
But those aren't the names that,
that uh,
that Kerner used
or more properly,
they are the names that he used,
but not to name the way we do it.
Now.
If anybody,
he had the right to name him,
but he didn't get it because he was off in left field down in Palermo and the
people up in Germany who are influential were the ones that finally named them.
Uh,
but notice that this argument is holds if benzene,
benzene is a hexagon,
but if it were a pentagonal pyramid or some other geometric structure,
then this argument wouldn't work at all.
Right?
So you have first to know that all the positions are equivalent and benzene,
that it's not like some of those doers structures we were just looking at.
So how can you do that?
This was proven in this paper in 1869 by Kerner,
the paper was published in Palermo,
in the journal,
the decency,
not rally at economic aid,
the Pell Eramo,
which is the Journal of Natural Science and economics of Polera.
It's a beautiful big journal with big wide margins on the pages and so on.
But it had no circulation,
whatever the people in Germany years later,
we're still trying to prove this,
what he proved.
Okay,
now here's a question.
Are the four valence as of carbon equivalent that is,
are they all the same or might want to have them be a sh,
a thick bond,
say different from the other three.
Right?
Or might it even be that that two of the bonds are different,
one's long or one of them's curly.
They might all four be different.
Can you think of any evidence to say that the bonds in methane are equivalent?
How could you prove this?
Alison,
you gotta do
what technique is current or using,
pardon me?
Counting isomers so what do you expect if you have four different bonds and
carbon,
right?
How many isomers would you get if there were four different,
oh,
you could have a chlorine on the fat bond.
The long bond,
the curly bond or the normal bond.
There'd be four.
Isomers if you could make them all and they didn't did or convert,
right?
So there's only one,
uh,
methyl chloride.
Nobody's found a second methyl chloride.
So does that prove that they're all equivalent?
Okay.
Yeah.
Pardon me?
Oh,
sounds good.
They can attach more than one.
They know that they all sort of,
they will work.
Okay.
That doesn't prove it alone because maybe there's only one that can be
substituted.
Right.
That is of the one,
if it have the structure on the right with four different bonds,
maybe you could make only one motto substituted one.
How many die substitute to ones could you make them?
Well,
the,
if the first one went in one place,
the second one could go any of three.
So you'd still say get three die substituted.
Unless you could only make one of those,
then there would only be two.
So it doesn't really prove it the way a mathematician would like things proven,
but it's a plausibility at least.
Okay.
But it turns out that that,
uh,
so the evidence is there's only one isomer known,
but it's not really proof.
Now current or in order to make a real proof had to make some assumptions.
And these,
he stated in 1867 two years before the paper we're talking about,
and the first is direct replacement.
And he wrote if one grants that in simple transformation,
the new substitute substituent assumes the position or the element displaced.
So you can take a substituent often put a new one there but it will go in the
same place that the old one came off.
Everything doesn't rearrange.
You need that in order to make arguments like he wants to make.
Right.
And in fact that's often true.
It's certainly logically parsimonious.
It's the simplest assumption you could make and it usually is true,
but there are Orain rearrangements that do sometimes occur and we'll talk about
those later on.
But anyhow,
he,
for his argument,
you have to assume direct replacement.
And the second assumption is that experimental distinguishability,
which we've been talking about,
most of the demonstrations are based on establishing the identity or difference
of several substances at the same composition,
but it obtained by different reactions.
So you have to be confident that you can tell when things are the same.
And when there are different,
we've just,
we're talking about that.
But currently was in an especially good position to do this because he was
really skilled in the lab.
In fact,
he got a silver medal at a Paris exposition,
one of these international exposition for his collection of beautiful crystals
that he had lovingly prepared and they had different shapes and so on.
That's one way you can tell things apart.
And in fact,
this bottle here,
uh,
says,
up at the top,
I don't think you can read it,
but it says laboratory.
Oh,
Dki Mika Organica and it says aussied AC Sally Sealy Eco.
So what is it?
Salycilic acid.
This is Kerner sample,
right of salycilic acid.
And here's his,
here are his beautiful crystals of two,
six [inaudible] three Bromo Tallinn you can't see them so well.
Well,
you can see that there's still beautiful crystal,
right?
So those are some of his prize crystals.
And here you can.
So crystals are the best way to tell them there pictures of those things that
were occurring.
Hers.
Okay,
now here's his proof based on those assumptions.
Okay.
So there are three known isomers of Hydroxy Car boxell benzene.
So you don't know anything about the structure.
All you know is u of c six h four.
You originally at c six h six but one of the H's has been replaced by Oah and
another age by Coh.
And the names of these things are salycilic acid,
which I just showed you.
Hydroxy benzoic acid and para hydroxy benzoic acid.
The names don't mean anything,
but those are just what the bottles are called right now.
You want to use the existence of at least three.
You don't,
there might be 18 for all you know,
die substituted ones.
All right?
But you know there are at least three is three and you can do experiments with
them.
So these are the experiments.
First you treat it with hcl and heat it up.
This was done by grave in 1866 and it loses the coh.
Remember we talked about how you could take benzoic acid,
take the coh off and have benzene here.
It's done.
Take the coh off,
but you're left with still the Oah and that compound,
as we mentioned before,
is called funnel,
right?
But you can do the same trick with para benzoic acid and you get the same
funnel,
not a different one.
What does that tell you?
It tells you that the difference between salycilic acid in para hydroxy benzoic
acid is not where the Oah is,
right?
They have to have the same position or the Ooh because,
or at least equivalent ones because you get the same funnel out.
And it was found also by gravy that you could convert hydroxy benzoic acid to
methyl Anna safe.
That's the Oah becomes o c h three and so same for the acid.
And then you can convert it to an acidic acid taking the ch three off on the
acid group from the ester.
That is to say,
and you can convert funnel by way of Bromo Anna Soul Kerner,
I believe did this.
And then by with sodium and co two to get the same monistic acid.
Right?
So the o position has to be the same in hydroxy benzoic acid is it was in salah
silicon para hydroxy.
Right?
So the conclusion is the difference among the three isomers that are known
salycilic hydroxy benzoic acid,
para hydroxy benzoate is not where the oil is.
Since the ohs survives in identical compounds.
So if for example,
it couldn't be like these three isomers of doers,
a structure here,
suppose that we're one of the acids and that were another one and that we're the
third.
Then when you took the coh off,
you'd have three different Oah compounds.
Everybody with me,
you see that?
So the difference among these three,
whatever it is that makes them different,
can't be where the Oah is because you can remove the coh and they're all the
same.
Okay.
For,
that's the first step.
And the conclusion is the sites occupied by Oah are either identical or
[inaudible] or equivalent.
Here's what's equivalent.
So suppose they could be this.
There's O,
did I?
Yeah,
here.
So you could have that.
Ooh,
that o h and that,
no,
there,
it's okay.
I'm sorry.
I'm messing this up.
There's one,
one,
two,
three.
The ohs in those are not the same position once the top right,
the others,
the top left,
but they're equivalent.
Right?
Once you got it,
you could flop it over and they're the same as one another.
Okay.
So we know at least that much.
So let's call the Oah position,
which is either the same or exactly equivalent,
call it Omega just for an Ame.
So always is in the position of h Omega that we know in all three compounds.
Can you guess what you do next?
Next?
Yeah,
probably,
ah,
take the Oah off and leave the COO h.
Right.
And that's possible too.
You can treat it with phosphorous,
Penta chloride,
which converts Oah to cl.
And then with sodium and water,
which takes the chlorine off and leaves hydrogen.
So you get benzoic acid and what do you do next?
Do it to one of the other compounds right there.
And you get the same benzoic acid or you do it here.
And I think Kerner is the guy who did that,
although I can't,
I haven't found a paper to that effect.
But anyhow,
he says that you get the same benzoic acid.
So what does that prove?
So the coh positions are not fundamentally different in the three compounds.
So the Oah positions are equivalent and also the coh positions are equivalent.
How can then then be different?
The three compounds because they're clearly different.
It must be their relative positions that are different.
Okay.
The the three isomers do not differ because of the absolute position of the Coh.
So the three sites of Coh are equivalent and we can name them x and Y and z.
None of them can be exactly the same because if they were exactly the same,
then the those hydroxy benzoic acid,
two of them at least would have been the same.
If the Coh is,
cause we know the ohs where the same.
Okay.
So for example,
it could be this way in doers Benzie you could have that position for x that for
why that fuzzy and they're all different with respect to omega.
Okay.
The Omega is,
we'll all be the same.
So that that would be a possibility.
Possible structure according to this,
in this particular case,
Omega would be the same as x,
Y andZ as a site for a single substituent if it were this structure.
So Rpa,
a chemist had made a compound,
which he called Nitro Antillean,
which was benzine that had Nh two and n o two in it.
And it was known by transformations.
The NH two was Omega,
that position,
Ooh,
Omega and the n o two was in why that is.
You could interconvert groups and make it into one of those known hydroxy
benzoic acid.
So you knew it was Omega and why.
Okay,
now you do a transfer and it's related to that particular hydroxy benzoic acid.
Okay.
Now you replaced the Nh two by br and we'll talk about these next semester.
What particular reactions did that and then you change an Otu to Nh two and then
you replace the Nh two by chlorine.
So now you've got benzene with bromine.
That must be in the Omega position because it replaced the first Nh and then
chlorine is in why?
Because substituted for the second Nh two which came from the n o two which was
in why.
Okay,
so it's Omega and why can you see what he's going to do next?
Yeah,
he replaces the Nh two by cl and then changes that o two to Nh two and then
replaces it by br.
Why?
So now he's prepared a compound,
which clearly has chlorine in the position,
Omega and bromine.
And the position.
Why
I see pursing of browse and so on.
Is everybody clear?
So he is prepared to come from the same compounds.
Could prepared a bromide chloride,
right?
One of them is Omega Bromide,
uh,
why chloride and the other has them exchange.
And what do you think he observed?
They're the same.
What does that show?
It shows that Omega is the same as why?
Because our while,
otherwise these be different.
When you put different atoms in,
I'm assuming you have the experimental technique to tell when things are
different.
Okay.
So now,
so it couldn't be,
for example,
a pentagonal pyramid,
which one had bromine and why?
And the other head,
chlorine and chlorine.
And why the other head chlorine in Omega and bromine.
And why it couldn't be that those would be different.
Okay.
So there must be at least four equivalent substitute positions.
Omega why x,
Y,
and Z.
Okay.
And that would be consistent with that structure we showed before this one.
So it could be that doesn't have to be a hexagon.
Yeah.
Now here's the next step.
So you start with a compound that's known to be in the meadow series.
It's got o,
h n Omega and Nitro,
n o two he wrote a z o two in x and you have another one that has again,
Ooh and the position Omega but bromine in x instead of Nitro,
right?
And now you start doing substitutions.
I remember he used Metta differently from the way we do.
Okay,
so first he put in a burrow,
mean someplace and then a nitro some place and got Bromo Nitro Mehta,
nitro funnel.
Okay.
You added the Bromo on the nitro group.
So you know that's the benzene core with h two with a nitro someplace with a
Bromo someplace.
Those are the ones you just put in.
But the era,
others are still where they were.
Oh h is in Omega and Nitro is in,
is in x position.
All right?
And now you go to the other compound and put in two nights groups.
So you don't know where those two nitro groups are.
But you know,
Omega is that Oha is in Omega and bromine is in X.
Everybody see what you've done now and you know what he observed?
Those two compounds are identical.
Can you see what conclusion you get from that?
These are identical,
right?
But one of them has bromine in x and the other has nitro in x.
How can they be identical?
There must be a second exposition.
That's equipment.
There must be two positions that are equivalent right now.
Could any of those positions be ones we already know?
Could it be omega?
Well,
we already know Omega x,
Y,
and z are the same,
right?
Could this new x be one of those?
Could it be omega?
No,
because we already got omega,
so it can't be omega.
Could it be y or z?
No,
because those would have started from a different compound in the first place if
it were Y or Z.
Right?
You know that this is in x.
It's not.
Why not z?
Right?
So there must be a second x.
All right,
we'll call it x prime.
Yeah.
There must be two positions,
x and x prime.
None up.
They're not equivalent to x or Y,
or they're not equivalent to x or y.
They're not the same as x or y or Z or Omega.
It's a new one.
Okay.
So that's what they are.
So there must be at least five equivalent positions now that would be consistent
with that Pentagonal Pyramid,
right?
All the five around the base of it,
or at five equivalent positions.
But you can't get three different dye substituted ones among those positions.
Right?
So it couldn't be that.
So none of doers models work with this.
Although the perfect hexagon will work a perfect one,
not alternating single and double bonds and the equal lateral triangular prism,
the Loddon Borg,
benzene,
we'll also work.
So as I said,
that it would work with either of those,
except that the one on the right,
uh,
doesn't give the right number of dice substituted isomers.
Now Kerner zone argument that the six position is equivalent was faulty because
it hinged in a subtle way on assuming that the benzene was huck hexagonal before
you proved it was,
it wasn't obvious,
but it's true if you look at it carefully.
But it is possible using group theory to construct a logically rigorous argument
on the basis of his evidence is last step of his argument was wrong,
but his evidence was adequate to prove it.
So he was right in his that this proved it and he was right in his conclusion
that all the positions are equivalent.
So he deserves enormous credit for formulating the logic of the first true
structural proof,
not just one of these plausibility things.
Like there's only one motto substituted methane,
Chloro Methane.
Therefore all the positions are equivalent.
Right.
That's just plausibility.
But this is a real rigorous proof.
Now how many isomers do you think there are of c two h four B r two
think about it.
Ethane with two bromines.
How many isomers
so pardon me,
somebody guest
John.
Great.
And how would you get three?
Oh No,
no double bond.
There are six things on it.
So forget that one.
Yep.
If we're double bonds,
you'd be right.
But there are no,
they'll want Corey.
And what would you call them?
How would you distinguish them or describe them?
[inaudible]
oh good.
So you could have two bromines on one carbon or one bromine on each carbon.
So there should be two isomers.
Now in that same journal,
the same volume at the same journal in 1869 in Palermo,
a guy named Paterno said the three isomers of Dye Bromo Ethane,
supposedly they actually exist,
can easily be explained without assuming any difference among the four valence
as of carbon.
You don't need curly bonds,
long bonds and stuff like that.
And here's how he explained it with this pictures,
right?
So both on the left,
most I have two on the same Adam,
the other two have one on each atom,
and how are they different?
One on each carbon atom.
But how do they differ
in the phase of rotation around the carbon carbon single bond?
Right?
And at the bottom he says,
or actually notice there's a little black thing in the middle.
What do you think it is,
Dana?
What do you think?
Right?
It's a piece of rubber tubing because this is an artist's picture of an actual
model made out of sticks and balls,
right?
And sure,
those things aren't super imposable.
Right?
And he's buddy says that,
that he says at the bottom,
it is superfluous to say that this is only a way of representing the facts and
that all these ideas need to be tested experimentally.
So we'll see next time.
What kind of reception this received.